ladies Congrats on the collection it is
so stunning but Kim what is it exactly
about Winnie's confidence that just
inspired this collaboration well I
definitely admire her confidence but and
I wouldn't need this fool to partner
with someone but just looking at her
face and this is like we did this side
by side face like head was so much
bigger than her she ever you know I was
really I loved like picking the photos
and going through that but you know I
love to partner with people that are
confident you know I did my first collab
with Mario and he is to me the ultimate
confidence of someone that just knows
exactly what look we're gonna do and has
always been really confident in his work
and what he brings to the table and I've
always loved that dynamic and so when I
wanted to partner with someone else and
Winnie
you know and I connected I just felt
like she is the ultimate modern
confident woman that and she knew
exactly what she wanted palette wise
color wise it made my job really easy
very nice and but she was on point but I
mean hearing all of these things from
Kim Wow oh my gosh right nope I mean
what does it mean to be a part of the
k'kaw beauty Empire oh wow
when you say it like that is very
intimidating but no it's an honor like
obviously I've been a huge fan of Kim
for so long so not only to like be
friends now but to actually get to work
and create together was insane to me
it's something that I never could have
even dreamt of but it's safe to say that
you guys have probably learned from one
another throughout the process so Kim
have you picked up any beauty tips from
Winnie and vice versa so any yeah I
think so I I don't know if you have like
look back at my beauty looks but if you
go and look at them you will notice I
wear mainly mattes a matte lip on that
eye and so mini it's been so much fun my
glam teams are dying
my judge brought out the callosity what
I realized that she does like her
specialty uh-huh
is she loves to line her lip and
whatever shade that she's feeling and
then put a nice sheer but like glitzy
glowy gloss on top so your lips just
look juicy but it has a tone of whatever
liner you want it to be Matt Matt Matt
and so this week has been so much fun
and so much juicier and yet you're
bringing the juice buddy so what if you
learned from good
I think everyone learned contouring from
Kim yes absolutely
George she's also queen of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians which is back and
in this season you've opened up about a
big health scare and perhaps depression
or anxiety that can come along with it
how do you have those difficult
conversations with the kids and I mean
it's North who's six if I'm not mistaken
and she even old enough to kind of
comprehend like mommy's going through a
tough time right now yeah no I
definitely keep that away from the kids
I think they're just too young to really
even realize if I'm in pain it was
really hard cuz I couldn't pick up the
kids for a while because I had a lot of
pain in my hands so until I figured it
out of what was really going on I really
needed to just like take a break from
lifting the baby and that was really
hard for me um my baby Chicago who's
like a big baby you know she's not like
but I was really worried that I had my
baby coming my baby boy and I just
thought it was gonna be really hard for
me so luckily I got it all under wraps
but when you do have a diagnosis or you
get tested for something and you get a
result that you weren't expecting you
definitely get in your head and you
start for a second you kind of get this
little depression of okay what are all
of the possibilities that can happen
what's my life gonna look like I really
want to be active for my kids and so it
triggers something but then I really had
to get myself together because I do have
I do have you know a family that I have
to just be positive and get it together
for so I believe no matter what's going
on in your life you can take that time
to grieve for a second no matter what it
is what you're grieving feel those
feelings and then figure out how to be
positive about it because it's not going
to change so there's no point in being
depressed and staying in that headspace
but I felt it for a minute and even good
things to take away from that then
you're healthy now everything's okay
everything's okay I'm on a medication
now so everything seems to be fine for
right now and I'm just rolling with it
day by day
you know I think Winnie can relate to
that she's someone that I called early
on about an issue that I feel like she
would really understand and she gave me
amazing advice and told me a lot of you
know stories that made me feel really
confident and that I could get through
that and so that's how Winnie and I
really connected before we even started
on the collab well I've got to tell you
we recently caught up with Tori Spelling
and Jennie Garth and they said they
would love for season two of Beverly
Hills 90210 to have you on as Tori's
boyar stop yes would you be are you
there seriously I'm there I mean yes I
like 9:02 a know to me was like my
childhood like I used to beg my dad for
this and I know - when I was sweat shirt
uh-huh I wish I still had it and then
because it's the best friend loja is
Brian's wife so I was watching the
premiere with her and so yeah I totally
would okay so I'm glad et is connecting
the dots you know but that's what that's
what we're here to do of course of
course
North full on fashionista Japan looks
like next level any of her fashion
rubbing off on you perhaps mom so North
is like my dream of what I wish I could
dress like really yeah because my body
type can't handle some of like the bag
year stuff and she is like what I wish I
get her what I wish I could dress like I
was walking through Saks
we're in sacks with Avenue right now
right I was walking through and I was
taking pictures on my phone of things
that she would love when I was tonight
and be like do you like this fabric
should we make this you know jacket for
you so going through lookbook it's not
bedtime story I love it
speaking of bedtime stories being at
home playing with the kids
you recently posted a pic of your two
little ones and they are dressed in some
western themed costumes oh my gosh have
you seen it Winnie it's so cute but
basically I mean this sounds like wah
wah West you guys are heading out west
to Wyoming you just purchased a house so
yeah is that something like you could be
packing up and moving out there entirely
well I heard the winters are intense so
I am going to have my husband feel that
out for me survive the fashions also no
winter time I go to all these vintage
stores I took my best friend Allison
last weekend we were going to like the
Boot Barn they're going all around these
places I love it there but I'm from LA
so I think I'll always be grounded in LA
but I love it there and I definitely
will be spending time there yeah I mean
Sunday service has become this
phenomenon when when have you ever been
we actually went the day that we shot
the cake aw yeah Sunday service and then
we ran to my mom's right we changed you
showered we changed and then we headed
off to work what a day but what is it
about Sunday service with Kanye that I
mean has just had people flocking to it
it's become a cultural phenomenon yeah I
think it was really interesting because
I've seen in fashion week some friends
emailed me like three fashion shows that
had like choirs and gospel music and I
think that's just so amazing I mean it
just you know for him it started off as
something that was really healing for
him and it was really small and really
personal and it grew and grew and he
really has been saved by Christ and it's
like born again and he dedicates his
whole life to the church and so it's not
like technically like he doesn't have
this like 501 3 C yet to make it a real
official
but it's a musical ministry I'd say and
if pastor friends are in town they'll
come and they'll say a few words if now
you know it's traveling to other
churches it's just become this amazing
thing and I do see online sometimes
people are like well what is it is it
just a gospel choir do they talk like it
is a Church of Christ it is a Christian
Church and it's an amazing gospel choir
it's really like about positivity and
healing I feel yeah now is this
something that is inspiring his upcoming
album that's dropping later this month
is it going to be a full-fledged gospel
album it is it is it is good crowd yes
yeah very cool well look Weerd amazing
it's really the sound is just so like I
need to bring my mom yeah I really do
yeah you can bring me too you want I
can't even explain the sound it's really
like healing
[Music]
you